it is just after 10 hours gmt we begin
this newshour with that developing news
out of ukraine where a team of u.n
experts is making a perilous journey to
assess the safety of europe's largest
nuclear power plant
both ukraine and russia are blaming each
other for the attacks near the
russian-occupied zaparagia nuclear plant
in southern ukraine that's led to hours
of delay to the un's much anticipated
mission to the facility there's been
heavy shelling in the area and along
their pre-arranged route ukraine's
nuclear agency says one of the six
reactors has been shut down because of
russian water attacks
i am going to consider the possibility
of establishing a continued presence
of the iaea at the plant which we
believe it's indispensable to stabilize
the situation and to get regular
reliable impartial neutral updates of
what the situation is there so wish us
luck we are moving now thank you for
your interest it's very important that
the world knows
what's happening here
live now two key foundry series teresa
beau is there teresa there's still some
doubt about what access this team will
actually get if they get to the plant
what's the latest on their trip
well since very early this thursday
morning there has been lots of shelling
around the nuclear power plant to use
the i aea team was located in around the
sapodilla region and they had to cross
the front line whereas a checkpoint by
ukrainian forces and then move forward
towards the russian checkpoints and
there's been some delays because of the
ongoing shelling and fighting that's
happening all around the area ukrainians
are saying that russian forces have been
shelling the city that a kindergarten
was hit a health facility that at least
three civilians were killed while
russian forces are saying that there was
an attempt from ukrainian forces to
attack the city and carry out some type
of an operation this has not been
confirmed however and what ukraine is
saying is that these are excuses by
russian authorities in a way to
intimidate and to control what's
happening and during this visit to the
iaea plant it's not clear yet what type
of access they're going to have
certainly we just heard uh rafael rossi
who's leading this team say that they're
going to continue they're going to be
there they're going to try to monitor
what's going on in the ground what type
of damage has happened the conditions in
which workers are currently uh doing
their job right they are under the
surveillance of russian forces uh
there's been some accusations of uh
torture of uh people have gone missing
among other things and that's a major
concern too and also of course that the
safety systems are in place because of
all this shelling we're hearing that one
out of the six reactors are only working
right now that the operational power
unit number five had to be shut down and
that the safety systems were activated
once again because of the ongoing uh
shelling around the area so certainly
you know the visit by the iaea is
crucial at this point it's a third party
that is going there to try to you know
evaluate what the situation is on the
ground
how close do we know
is this shelling to the nuclear plant
what are the risks surrounding it
well it's important to explain what's
been going on here you know since russia
took over the plan they took over the
city where the plant is located they
established a military base from there
and from there they have been launching
attacks towards the ukrainian front line
and the ukrainian forces have been doing
the same so it's not clear what type of
damage has happened what we have seen
however is that many of the rockets many
of the shells have been falling very
very close to where the nuclear power
plant is located in fact just a few days
ago some shelves fell very very close to
where the nuclear fuel is located and
where the radioactive waste is located
and of course this raises lots of
concerns in fact we know that
authorities around the area we're
already distributing iodine pills to the
population iodine is supposed to prevent
the thyroid gland from absorbing
radiation in case there's a leak so
certainly there's a big concern about
what's going to happen there today the
level of damage and that's why it is so
important for the iaea team to make it
there it's not clear yet when they're
going to arrive it is expected to happen
today at least that's what the director
has been saying that they won't be
stopped in spite of the violence and the
shelling that has been ongoing there al
jazeera's teresa beau reporting live
there from keeve many thanks indeed to
teresa well russia's foreign minister
insists that moscow is upholding its end
of security guarantees for the new the
eon nuclear inspectors
[Music]
we are doing everything to ensure that
the plant is safe and for the iaea
mission there to carry out all of its
plans
they say that they are not in a position
to say who is in the wrong of course
they would be shown all those traces
left as a result of ukrainian
bombardments ukrainian shelling we
insisted that the mission must include
experts in ballistics so i hope we are
going to find out or rather we know
everything but i hope that the
international community will get this
opportunity too
let's bring in tarek rauf who's a
nuclear arms control specialist who
formerly worked for the iaea he joins us
now live from vienna good to have you
with us sir what do you make of what you
heard there from russia's foreign
minister just how dangerous a situation
is this right now
well from all the news reports it seems
that the iaea team led by director
general grossi
is at a checkpoint about 20 kilometers
away from the zaparia nuclear power
plant and one could hear
uh shells exploding in the in the
background so i think this is a very
dangerous mission
and uh
full credit to the iaea team to
try to get to zapposia under this
wartime condition and what do you make
of the fact that we're hearing that one
of the nuclear reactors at the site has
been shut down because of the shelling
well actually of the six reactors two
have were already in shutdown status and
only two have been operating at any one
time over the past several months so of
the two uh reactors one as your
correspondent reported was shut down
probably because of loss of electrical
power so each uh reactor unit has the
backup generators three diesel electric
generators as well as two backup so the
zapo asia nuclear power plant does have
a backup power supply but however we
still need the nuclear power plants to
run on regular
transmission power not backup diesel
generators so once this team of un
inspectors gets to the plant
what will they be doing there
well it seems that the team has three
sets of experts uh one group will assess
the nuclear safety systems the safety uh
systems of the plants the safety of the
fuel the emergency shutdown the
emergency core cooling and the power
supply
another team will assess the security
situation the physical security
situation the damages and so on and the
third team will be looking at the
nuclear material
and doing nuclear material accountancy
and servicing the iaes cameras and seals
uh in the nuclear fuel ponds and the
reactor areas
i i don't want to get into the realms of
uh speculation or scare mongering but i
i'm just interested to know that if the
shelling going on around the nuclear
plant what what happens if
if it takes a direct hit
well it depends on the type of shell as
the power plant's containment structure
has a thick steel liner covered by a
concrete
cover but no nuclear power plant is
designed to survive a war situation or
hits from artillery shells so any firing
of any type in the vicinity of a nuclear
power plant is very irresponsible and
extremely dangerous and once the team
leaves the site having completed their
inspection if they get to do that
then what
well under normal circumstances the
director general would return to vienna
and uh
issue a report to the iaea's board of
governors he probably will give a press
briefing on arrival at vienna airport uh
and the board of governors is scheduled
to meet uh the week after next uh maybe
they have an emergency meeting depending
on the report and the security and
safety situation of zaparisia
and then based on that whatever are the
needs that zapatia will need to be met
in terms of providing extra equipment
rotation of personnel
uh
pleading with both sides to stop any
firings
and
activities such as that good to talk to
you sir many thanks indeed for being
with us tonight off there in vienna